[Musica]
stamattina si è imposta che anche lei
deve partecipare al video se non era
contento i ragazzi e benvenuti sono
video sono la vj e lei è la mia pustola
siamo tornati su uomo che fuma e beve si
tatua simulator anche chiamato the
higher la war games sarebbe un gioco
dove bisogna indovinare quale tra le due
cose è più popolare quale ti popolare
tra chiari a chi non ho mai capito come
cazzo si pronuncia il suo nome è the big
bang theory credo david 20 orima di
brutto
e mica è neanche troppo in realtà ma
sono ancora peggio the big bang theory e
alcolisti anonimi va bene credo david 20
ore poi dio mio
c'è troppa gente alcolizzata al mondo
non ci avevo fatto caso ragazzi di
proprio che c'è stich susanna puopolo
fatto al mondo cioè mondo dal cazzo ciao
ragazzi di proviamoci anche se non coca
cola e al rapid eye movement movimento
veloce con gli occhi perché è un
cristiano dovrebbe cercare movimento
veloce con gli occhi ho detto no 9900
infatti che la rapid eye movement
emanuel noi è bravo no higher para lusso
rigore a perle bayern ci mettevamo pelle
era 10 volte tanto ragazze mettevamo
surreal power ancora di più fra manuel
hoyer e windows l'inerme bisogno
windle cleaner pulitori di vetri di
grattacieli non vesse incula nessuno
diventate manuel noi era na na cake and
eating disorders banana kate è certo che
a tutti quanti piace la banana key che
non c'è verso eating disorders e window
clinica non mi ricordo più l'ho fatto un
secondo fa come quanto aveva fatto
window cleaner disturberà order che curò
il pianista e luisa melis per forza
erano pari veramente tra lewis e
prosecco ma perché il prosecco nome
prosecco ma facce lucas non capisco
perché ci stanno di stilizzate la
prosecco idee ma cos'è il santo iddio
vabbè ciao ciao proprio tra prosecco e
cena this item dovevate promettere
l'immagine della testata samp ed io
guarda materazzi come contento di questa
cosa si come manuel noi era aveva 4 50
secondo me zidane e per zidane e
allenatore ma si dai facciamo il quale
nessuno si dà che palle ma edizione tra
i sette samurai e city lights books in
the life e [ __ ] va in pannelli
solari e genere che cazzo ne so general
motors sangue dio 6 milioni che culo tra
general motors e al the dragon trainer
minchia general monica tra contrino non
è così tanta infatti meno male tra
dragon trainer there will be there be
there will be blu del rubava affanculo
questo già ci aveva il nome del merlo
sapevo io che ho sbagliato teacher
training teacher training non avrebbe
14.000 ricerche se fosse veramente
cameron diaz fare l'attrice ma ne
avrebbe tipo più del porno nord morti
tragiche morti ma che cazzo è ma non ho
idea
ma cos'è sta roba 3 milioni ma cosa vuol
dire a mutuo silca mutuo morte
ma che ne so io frega cazzi dei mutui
secondo me avrebbe comunque più ricerchi
a cameron diaz la veyron five e xfactor
risolse mm un file per forza santo gesù
benedetto tra democrazia e breaking bad
ma secondo me breaking vende né a 3
milioni
secondo me minchia show il calcolatore
qui cazzo a volte mi spavento la sua
quasi erano lira breaking bad e
paramount picture and kings ed edificio
prove nestlè e vin diesel a san pedro
vin diesel che comanda 90 gente cerca
vin diesel tra vin diesel e johnny cash
ma figurati miglia non c'era mai così in
alto giorni 10 ma cazzo 2 milioni e
passa giorni che esce the jacksons
ma non si rincula nessuno i jackson iii
the jacksons hhh vita hhh o non è mica
così tanto cercato hhh andava quando era
piccolo che sputava l'acqua tipo vapore
mica io ogni volta che prova fa sta roba
sembrava un paziente psicopatico con la
schiuma alla bocca che gli usciva non so
come trippa lei se tu hai van breemen
hhh si è però non di tantissima già alto
sicuro di più che cazzo per niente
ragazzi l'hanno cambiato sto gioco
diventato difficilissimo sono iwata 8
monaco grandprix del rubbio ferro bios
per forza rubiu sino se poco cercato
calcio mi sa che tra tutti super rubio
se segway se spero i segway scasso
celine cura nessuno seguito se selena
gomez selena gomez tutta la vita madonna
9 milioni e 140mila ricerche delle quali
9 milioni sono solo mie
selena gomez e spa direi selena gomez
guarda però anche spa se la gioca spa e
ford miyake domanda di mortacci vostri
me pio nafia tra francia e los angeles
al santo iddio francia penso
tra los angeles e fame nel mondo sarà
purtroppo los angeles sono convintissimo
vabbè ma cala madonna perché mi devi
fare un concerto a trani nel mondo e
kamasutra spiegami che problemi al
cervello c'hai kamasutra novara non
siamo proprio dubbi aggiungi kamasutra e
cameron diaz e vedi come sarà ancora di
più tra kamasutra e bob dylan
kamasutra nokia [ __ ] crociera quanto
cedeva suo cazzo di titolo che non
riesco a nominare l'ho mica non lo
ricordavo there will be blood e amazon
rain forest amazon amazon già solo per
la parola amazon invece non sono il culo
a nessuno
sei arrivata dieci regali scritto a come
lo ero messo l'altra volta siccome è
diventato difficilissimo sto cazzo di
gioco non so perché va già bene faccia
molto bene che poi da altri ragazzi vi
do una notizia o l'ho letto recentemente
tipo pokémon go è diventato più popolare
del porno in questo periodo non so
perché c'è no in realtà lo so perché la
gente si masturba sui pokémon però
quello un altro discorso è compreso è
pavi vorrai mica dirmi che cerchi più
pokémon go che i porno no abbiamo spazio
tutte e due ne faccio un'altra ragazzi
solo per capire se riesco a superare i
10 rsi madison sesta fila c'è questa qua
e famosa sta tizia quel famoso solo dal
dal naso in giù vuoi sopra non si vede
ma mi adoratissima selena gomez facciamo
lower stone age è infatti il santo iddio
ashley madison tra vecchie read e
madonna dell c'avrà tipo 8 milioni
ricerche robe così quattro tra jobs e
wells fargo mi pare che sia una banca
americana l'ho vista quando sono andato
a los angeles
penso alla banca credo poi non si sono
state calmi tra wells fargo e madonna ma
non ama veramente mi capiti clash of
lies l'altro vorrei fare comica non
penso che c'è un po di differenza è tra
i due papà giusto un attimo tra tazza
void ansie alzheimer alzheimer ecco
infatti che tutte le persone che lo
cercano poi non si ricordano di averlo
cercato e quindi lo ricercano alzheimer
e cannabis cannabis ragazzo li siamo
arrivati a 10 6 azzecco questa è record
per l'episodio è perché il mio record
della tipo 17 però era più semplice
prima mi cadesse difficilissimo tra
cannabis e betty boop cannabis che culo
se buco del culo serio non lo sapevano
da betty boop e islam considera quanta
gente ci sta nella foto islam però non
so quanti di loro abbiano internet
quindi 9 da islam
ok ce l'hanno in tanti internet un
milione sono tanti e ragazzi però
oroscopo credo ne abbia rifiutato sono
ariete dove ariete serie teen in aries
mango sapere qualche big horn che ciò su
cornuto raramente mi chiedo allo scopo
lo cercano tutti
porca vacca l'altro polo allo scopo già
più di crash o france pure quello tra
oroscopo e impianti per le tette
oroscopo sicuro ragazzi stop sto
abbinamento lo dovete vedere e geniale
impianti per le tette e spongebob
ma per ceppo tutta la vita convinto è
infatti tra spongebob e handball
spongebob
ok identificare i ladri
handball che cazzo ne so ragazzi si è
fatto questo è il record 17 non li ho
mai fatti neanche nell'altro episodio lo
ha fatto prima ragazzi mi pare che fosse
meno credo è porca [ __ ] tra risultati
di xfactor e tatuatore tatuatore tutta
la vita sincero e non me l'aspettavo
teatro ma grazie di cuore ai ragazzi tra
link i nidi truman è il 18 che credo sia
il nuovo record e di aver fatto 17 la
crota non me lo ricordo
spero che video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
spero che anche a voi interessino gli
impianti per le tette perché dio santo
se vi è piaciuto così tanto momento è un
mi piace anche a pagine di facebook e
come tiziana sensi di scrittrici vediamo
proseguito era ragazzo